ist es denn möglich dass die ukraine
gewinnt über russland in den augen naja
was heißt in gewinnen in diesem krieg da
gebe ich ihr sogar eher wenig über die
kaje oder ihr reihe müssen die tun das
prüfung sind kleiner diejenigen
was heißt die die ukraine sondern auch
ein hockeyspiel was da stattfindet
natürlich nicht sagen kann und im
überall ist es auch durchaus von
diversen klugen leuten auch in diesem
land schon aufgegriffen worden die
ukraine haben schon mehrfach punkte
definiert was ist für sie heißen könnte
ob es um die frage einer nato
mitgliedschaft in der eu mitgliedschaft
ging ob es um die frage der
unabhängigkeit des donners team unter
deutscher führung aber auch die krim
frage ja dort hat es sozusagen angebote
gegeben aber es gibt von putin
spätestens seit dem vorfall die überfall
und den versenkung des kriegsschiffes
gibt es von putin keine
verhandlungsbereit auf keiner ebene mehr
das heißt noch einmal es sind nicht die
ukraine nicht bereit wären zu verhandeln
putin ist ist derzeit nicht das heißt
das einzige ziel so bitter wie das für
alle beteiligten ist die russen eine
lage zu bringen in der man am ende
beiden seiten die putin den russen und
die lenski der ukraine einen wie auch
immer gearteten kompromiss verkaufen
kann das heißt es wird kampfhandlungen
geben zu glauben dass dieser krieg
sanktionen oder durch verhandlungen
allein entschieden wird ist glaube ich
tatsächlich nein ich es wäre schuldig
aber es wird nicht sagen es ist eine
ganz einfache frage die ich noch mal
stellen darf vielleicht um sie zu
kontextualisiert wer hat wen überfallen
die russen die ukraine oder klein
überfall oder gleich noch einmal mein
erstes opfer das futter als die schuld
daran sein dass die überfallen werden
das hat genau das getan es hat nie noch
konnte schon realisieren ist ein brief
dass nicht er das ein schritt ist gerne
sagen wir nicht ausreden ich hab ich ja
gar nicht also ich kann muss kann nur
sagen lassen sie mich reden geben sie
mir eine wortspende
also ich hab ja und nochmals nach 24
stunden gesagt habe oder was weiß ich
als alles was gesagt habe die ältere
erinnern sich sicher
ich bin froh dass dieser brief in der
welt ist weil er gewisse dinge geklärt
weil es viele leute dieser republik gibt
die viele tendenzen dieses briefes
teilen das ist gut dass wir drüber reden
ich teile viele tendenz in diesem brief
nicht das muss ich auch klar sagen aber
es ist gut dass er in der öffentlichkeit
ist die beiden punkte die mich vor allem
stören weil ich das sagen darf ist zum
einen ist klang eben schon kurz an dass
es einmal heißt der berechtigte
widerstand gegen einen aggressor stehe
in einem unerträglichen missverhältnis
zu dem leid dass man produziere wenn man
waffen liefern so ein wenig den eindruck
als wird man in der ukraine nicht
erweckt stark den eindruck also mit der
ukraine sagen irgendwann ist mal gut mit
dem widerstand und das finde ich
natürlich sehr paternalistisch von außen
das geht überhaupt nicht wenn eine
nation sich entschlossen hat lieber
stehend zu sterben als kind zu leben
dann ist das eine entscheidung die man
erst mal akzeptieren muss und das 2 das
ist für die waffenlieferung herr kessler
ich bin für ich bin nicht für endlose
waffen liefert momentan muss man der
ukraine waffen liefern und man kann ihn
nicht vorschreiben was sie bedienen
können und was sich also das geht
einfach nicht wenn wir an der seite der
ukraine stehen darf das nicht folgenlos
rhetorik bleiben müssen sie mit waffen
jetzt unterstützen klar und der zweite
punkt ist wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass
ist leider gottes auch verbreitet dass
wir putin ein motiv zu einem
gegebenenfalls verbrecherischen hansen
liefern da wird natürlich auch sagen
herr putin braucht gar keine motive
handelt ja verbrecherisch spätestens
seit dem überfall wenn ich vorher schon
durch seine aktionen in der ukraine den
souveräner staat ist und dieses narrativ
zu übernehmen nach dem motto wir dürfen
den russischen bären nicht reizen dann
schlägt der umsicht und macht ganz
schlimme dinge wenn er einmal aus der
höhle heraus ist er ist so längst aus
der höhle er ist nicht mehr an der kette
und sich zu sehr in den kopf dieses
mannes hineinzubegeben und jeden schritt
zu verlassen der ihn noch mehr reizen
könnte obwohl er sich bereits als jemand
erwiesen hat der eher rational zu
handeln im stande ist das halte ich also
für zu viel mit füllung zu viel
einfühlung und deshalb für nicht
vernünftig dass werden das war ein
eindrucksvoller frage und zwar hier gab
es ja den vergleich von herr bruder auch
zwischen putin und hitler würden sie da
auch mit den häcksler dass man das
vergleichen kann löst das könnte hier
unterrichten
also gehen sogar noch weiter ich bin
generell kein freund von von hitler
vergleichen also ich würde keinem ich
würde keinem dazu raten weil was ist das
für eine erkenntnis stiftende kategorie
werden gar keine also ich rate generell
von von von hitler vergleichen ab ist
jedes böse hat in sich seine eigene maß
an deren wertigkeit und man muss
versuchen das böse jeweils aktuellen die
schranken zu weisen er hilft uns
überhaupt nichts mehr sagen bin ich aber
ähnlich wie hitler das ist das was mir
solchen obsession zu und hitler ist
nicht so dass gut die matif böse ist
auch die benchmark für das böse
überhaupt der massenmord und der
völkermord fängt für uns bei 6 millionen
an alles darunter sind
ordnungswidrigkeiten alles drunter
bekommt von uns den rat sich nicht zu
verteidigen sie würden wahrscheinlich
auf den leuten im warschauer ghetto den
rat gegeben haben herr broder nicht zu
kämpfen um die opferzahlen nicht zu
erhöhen ihr standpunkt ist sowas und
unmoralisch so was von unanständig
selbstsüchtig mit einem einzigen wort
national aber er muss sich einer so gern
von ihnen so titulieren ich sage noch
einmal wenn ein krieg nicht beendet wird
dann gibt es interessen und diese
interessen sind jenseits des gemetzels
was da vor ort stattfindet ja mario pohl
und so weiter ich gucke mir die bilder
auch an und ich bin entsetzt ich habe
zufällig auch zwei söhne 28 und 30 und
ich möchte da nicht sehen ich bin
tatsächlich
natürlich nicht aber ich möchte einfach
nur mal sagen dass ich irritiert bin
dass ich in der bundesrepublik 2022
einem land das sich einem frings
narrativ europa angeschlossen hat 70
jahre frieden auf diesem kontinent auf
einmal binnen zehn wochen ein
kriegsgeheul und gerade zu einer kriegs
lust verspüren muss ja wenn ich in die
berichterstattung gucke dass wir wenn
ich in den spiegel gegeben hat der
bundesrat wirklich rede davon dass wir
zwei lehrern
dass wir ihn von dem ersten moment an wo
ich erleben muss dass wir auf einmal ein
sondervermögen haben für 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr auf einmal alles über
den berg gekippt haben was mal eine
station dieses landes war nämlich
militärische zurückhaltung dass wir
keine waffen liefern in kriegsgebiete
ich gucke auf die grünen und frage mich
nur was ist aus dieser partei geworden
führen kann also dagegen ging wollte
genau aber die grünen sind mir passiert
wird im september noch mit plakaten von
annalena baerbock keine waffen in
kriegsgebiete das heißt wir haben hier
einen massiven verrat europäischen
werten ich würde das gerne einmal
thematisieren und damit sage ich vision
und damit sage ich nicht dass wir
darüber nachdenken müssen wir den
ukrainern helfen aber ob wir ihn mit
schwerem gerät helfen das ist die frage
die auf dem tisch liegt was überhaupt
unsere ziele sind das können wir nicht
so richtig definieren und das ist das
was ich vertreter miro sind 70 jahre
europa frieden jahren eine vision ist
schön dass ich negativ genannt haben
schlimmer wäre es gewesen sie hatten
realität genannt und es ist tatsächlich
nicht mehr als ein narrativ und das ist
genau das problem das auch in ihrem
brief zum auszug kommt deswegen ist es
auch mein mut das ja ich habe
das versprechen wie es meine in alice
schwarzers brief und und dem brief der
der unterzeichner dass man im grunde ein
narrativ eine vision ein wunschdenken
zur realität erklärt das ist eins der
großen dilemma deutsche aber auch
mitteleuropäischer politik seit langem
dass man die realität schlicht
ausblendet die dna der menschen hat sich
aber nicht geändert und kriege werden
werden und wurden und denken sie bitte
auch an den gern in der öffentlichkeit
nicht so sehr thematisierten bei krieg
kriege werden die ganze zeit geführt vor
unseren augen oder über das kann nicht
von allen ich gehöre
ja mal gerne wissen was überhaupt
einklagen und die werden ja mit das
problem ist das ist nicht richtig wir
schaffen werde ich bringe heute aber
überhaupt kein verständnis dafür dass
wir mit diesem brief letztlich auch eine
öffentlichkeit in diesem land
suggerieren das ist diese möglichkeit
die sie dort ja noch nicht mal konkret
beziehen sondern nur wünschen dass es
die aktuell überhaupt gibt an dass man
so den frieden und gar die freiheit
erhalten kann ich weiß was ich in
maschad reden wir haben das ist ja in
europa auge erdigen sie freiheit es gibt
die europäischen werte nicht sind wir
uns bei fragen wie dem die migrations
verhalten sind für uns bei frage wie dem
asylrecht sind wir uns beim sozialstaat
sind wir uns bei fragen von religion und
familie einig wir haben in den ländern
keinen konsens und noch weniger debatte
leider wir haben ihn grenzübergreifenden
europa schon gar nicht sonst muss man
definieren ist die europäische realität
polnisch oder ist die deutsch
da ist die ungarisch oder ist die frage
also dieser art realität gibt es jede
menge kurzweil ha di gärn sie hätten sie
gern aber sie gibt es in dieser frage
nach und allen anderen zwischenfragen
auf diesen kontinent allem auch nicht
ich sage nochmal wir hatten 70 jahre
frieden auf diesem kontinent und
diejenigen die gestern noch die freiheit
abgeschafft haben um leben zu retten
wollen jetzt leben
riskieren eine interessante die
elektrische kurzschlüsse aus in prag
tauss in ungarn haus in polen aus
deswegen sage ich froh über die
friedliche revolution und europe online
free und mein ganzes lebenswerk sind 30
jahre arbeit an der europäischen
integration und dann ever closer juni in
diesem falle nicht gleich
sagen was noch eine andere obszönität
ist diese hier in großer gelassenheit
warum es ausgerechnet ab sondern auch
und einer saison nein ich lasse es nicht
außer sie las dass kontextualisierung
habe ich ja schon vielen dank ich hab
also ich würde meinen ankommenden arten
konnten risikolos hier verbreitet werden
weil leute wie sie hier viele jahrzehnte
unter dem schutze der amerikaner lebt
und alles was ihnen einfällt zu amerika
ist dass amerika ein paar kriege
gestartet hat eine fadenscheinige fehlen
ja nach ihrem 41 vielleicht ein paar zu
wenig die haben sie alles überhaupt
nicht dass es nicht nur sagen will ist
gemacht ich wollte die schleichende
amerika haben oder darin ist sich dann
sagen zwei drittel der kriege die nach
1949 geführt worden sind von amerika
ausgegangen ist können sie nachlesen das
sind zahlen statistische zahlen so das
einzige was ich sage die kriege haben
wir nicht gesehen wir sind nicht bei
bagdad gewesen um die iraker gegen
amerika zu verteidigen wir sind doch
nicht so weit weg aber da wie auch immer
von kabul und in disaster das ist ja
erst im september gewesen will ich gar
nicht wissen war sowie kostenlose
straubing blenden ja ganz egal ob syrien
jemand so weit haben immer ausgeblendet
jetzt ist es in der ukraine und nur weil
es in der ukraine ist wird es derart
eskaliert bis hin zu der eskalation ich
sage es noch mal dass wir inzwischen
tatsächlich denken wir könnten
kalkuliert eine nukleare
eskalation in kauf nehmen ich finde das
einfach horrible
machen sie nicht zu